I'm sick of this I work hard for my mom
cardi B is officially off Instagram okay
after the rapper won Best Rap Album at
the Grammys on Sunday haters were quick
to chime in on social media pitting her
against two else Nicki Minaj but the
tension hit an all-time high when the BT
Network agreed in a sense deleted and
apologized for post sending cardi into
an all-out not-safe-for-work expletive
filled rant on Instagram and let my
style for people to put other people
down to uplift somebody else that's not
my style and that's not what I'm with
and I don't support that
however I've been taking a lot of today
I'm feeling out today and I saw a lot
last night
and I'm sick of this I work hard for my
if you think cardi stopped there well
you're wrong
the I like a trapper continued her rant
by reflecting on the reactions from last
year's Grammys so just a little
refresher cardi earned two nominations
in Best Rap performance and best rap
song for her track beau dak yellow but
didn't win either one I remember last
year when I did it one for for that
yellow ever I was that party guys no
party with a guy snow now this here's
the problem this is a lot I'm tired but
there's more my full-time platinum on
and every chart that it was Marvel was
always top ten number one album as well
cardi did not slow down defending her
Grammy win and noting how she quote
worked her ass off and spent endless
hours in the studio all the while being
pregnant with her daughter culture lab
myself in the studio put three months my
didn't went to sleep in my own bed
sometimes before gate straight pregnant
some songs today began on the album
because my nose was so dumb people my
pregnancy
couldn't sleep Kendall why everybody was
surpassing me like you're not gonna do
it
we know you pregnant your
so this video wasn't up long before
cardi deleted it and then she
deactivated her Instagram but before she
went insta m.i.a she shared another
cleaner response on Instagram about all
the work that went into making invasion
of privacy quote I listen to my album
and I cry because I know the hell I went
through doing the album is always a
bittersweet memory thank you everyone
that supported me and listen I'm
thankful and grateful advil cardi may
not be on instagram anymore at least we
can count on her man offset to provide
us with some quality cardi content the
migos rapper released the new teaser for
his upcoming solo album and documentary
on Instagram Sunday and get this
it features never-before-seen real-life
home video of cardi giving birth to
their little girl let's watch that
dramatic zoom in one more time off sets
face is literally all of us and I am
dead
she was also by cardi side on Sunday as
she won her first ever Grammy and let me
tell you something these two had me
feeling some feels oh my goodness Oh
ciao
how cute are they I can't you guys of
course cardi also thanked her hubby for
his love and support you husband thank
you
Nasser's because he was that oh you
won't do this album girl we will have
this baby and we're gonna make this
album in December she announced she had
split from offset but it looks like all
is fine and dandy now I asked you if you
and offset of working things out
and you said we're working working you
know yeah working it out yeah
taking this low um this looks faster
than slow just check out their PDA on
the red carpet color me super
uncomfortable but of course we'll have
all the latest cardi and offset news for
you so be sure to subscribe to all
things et until next time I'm at Halle
underscore Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]